[Music]
did you know that there are over 50
million animal species in the world and
over 10,000 new species are discovered
every year you wouldn't believe how
awesome some of them look ever heard of
a pink fairy armadillo or okapi stay
tuned to find out more about these
cool-looking creatures if you'd love to
watch more videos like this one don't
forget to click the red subscribe button
today we'll show you ten common animals
that look out of this world the Mexican
salamander also known under its official
name as the axolotl this walking fish
definitely deserves the title of one of
the coolest ocean species their name
which roughly translates into water dog
originates from Aztec God mythology as
their name suggests they can be commonly
found in Mexican lakes Mexican
salamanders are typically brown and come
with four furry gills on each side you
can also find completely white
salamanders in zoos and laboratories
they don't really have any teeth but
they still swallow worms mollusks and
even small fish doesn't look just like a
pokemons you probably heard of his
cousin the tiger salamander Black
Panthers Black Panthers are probably one
of the most majestic creatures out there
just look at this furry cat America
calls them black Jaguars while Asia and
Africa refer to them as black leopards
their skin pattern depends on their
genes every black panther comes with
cool looking spots some of them are just
less visible due to their dark fur this
fierce dark cat is one of the greatest
predators it's smart fast and it can
leap up to 20 feet they're mighty look
and fierceness earned them an important
symbol courage valor and power
Liger ever heard of ligers we swear
we're not making this up they're a
combination of tigers and lions and are
known as the world's largest cats often
found in zoos with a mix of line fur and
tiger stripes these animals sure look
incredibly majestic and powerful an
average liger can grow to 12 feet one of
the biggest ligers goes by the name of
Hercules
it weighs 922 pounds and it even made
the Guinness Book of World Records
although zoos may have to separate
tigers and lions many will crossbreed
them and create interesting looking
loggers
a rooster roosters might be very common
but did you ever notice how cool they
actually look look at their colorful
feathers there are more than 50 chicken
species and each of them comes with a
different color roosters are the lucky
ones and are more colorful than a female
chicken although they have the ability
to fly their weight usually stops them
from reaching more than a couple of feet
you will very rarely see a flying
rooster roosters have been around for a
very long time and they play an
important symbolic part in almost every
religion and culture in China a rooster
symbolizes fortune luck and protection
leafy sea dragon check this out
these sea dragons can only be found
along the southern and western coast of
Australia nicknamed leafy's these sea
dragons are definitely one of the
coolest looking animals ever their leap
like protrusion serve as a camouflage
they make it seem like these creatures
are nothing but a regular sea weed sea
dragons eat by slurping up their fruit
through their long straw-like nose they
can grow up to 14 inches in length and
can remain still for very long periods
of time leafy sea dragons have recently
been crowned as the oceans most stunning
creatures and we can definitely see why
bearded vulture commonly seen in the
mountains of Europe Asia and Africa
bearded vultures closely resemble an
eagle they come in many different colors
you can find them in any shade from pure
white to orange red they're one of the
largest vultures in the world can grow
almost 4 feet tall and live until
they're 45 years old they'll usually rub
red soil into their feathers to look
more intimidating an orange bearded
vulture symbolizes their the worst
smartest and most vicious of them all
but if you ever happen to see one you
should run as fast as you can
these powerful looking creatures survive
by eating carcass okapi okapi is one of
the last remaining ancestors of a
giraffe which is one of the tallest
animals on earth it looked like an
interesting mix between a zebra and a
giraffe and they can be commonly found
in mountain forests of Central Africa an
okapi can grow up to 6.5 feet and reach
a speed of 37 miles per hour their
herbivore diet is very colourful and
they typically eat more than a hundred
different types of plants even though
they weren't discovered as a species
until the 20th century there are
about 22,000 okapis in the world red
panda
if pandas aren't cool enough to you wait
until you see a red panda this panda
also called the red Bearcat resides at
China and Eastern Himalayas
they resemble a raccoon but each red
panda comes with individual markings on
their firm that's exactly what makes
them so unique they come with a long
stripey tail that can measure up to 20
inches they might look cute but be
careful red pandas have sharp
retractable claws hidden inside their
paws as odd as it sounds they're
vegetarian carnivores they come from a
meat-eating family but will very rarely
eat anything other than bamboo slots
what did we do to deserve slots they
mostly live in Central and South America
but it seems like the entire world
managed to fall in love with them they
come with very long 4-inch claws which
they used to climb and hang from tree
branches they grow to 27 inches and can
weigh almost 19 pounds did you know that
they're the world's slowest animals its
scientific name Brad a puss actually
means slow feet one of the best features
of slots are their mouths they look like
they're always smiling and having a good
time no matter what they're doing
blobfish
forget that blobfish was actually named
one of the world's ugliest animals its
unique features made it to our list a
blobfish can be found in the deep waters
of Australia Tasmania and New Zealand
despite its odd slimy look this creature
is actually completely harmless and very
rarely seen they have very little
muscles and pretty much spend their time
just floating around they grow to about
12 inches and it pretty much leads a
quiet life in the bottom of the ocean
and survives lazily by swallowing
smaller fish we wonder if it knows about
its reputation on land what's your
favorite animal let us know in the
comment section below
for more animal facts check out our
friends at the taco and their video on
ten unusual creatures you won't believe
exist
[Music]
you